assalamualaikum guys guess who's with me
here in Chicago Salam alaikum how are
you why they come we set our hotel over
the katsu and hummed I'm doing very well
anyhow are you alright good we're gonna
have some lunch and then we're gonna go
ahead and talk and catch up and would
you guys like to be a part of the
conversation great you would okay I'll
be right back with more know Mike I just
heard the story about Hajj and Umrah and
many people and I let him file it with
Sheikh go ahead and share this with us
it really touched me and shall not touch
you guys to going explain what you were
telling me so you know when Allah when a
lot of people think about
their approaches you know what it's
nomination upon me let me just get it
done and over with we don't realize that
I just actually a gift from Allah
subhanAllah not only is an opportunity
to your brothers and sisters all over
the world not only an opportunity to
worship or less fine without it together
but almost finally that gives you so
much in edge one of the stories I'd like
to share is that you know my family we
were trying to have a child for quite
some time but unless finds out I didn't
will it yet last year I made the
intention to go for hajj and a few
months later i come dude I lost mine
without a blessed us you know with my
wife getting pregnant to come
and that's just one example other
brothers are trying to get married
literally within weeks they were able to
find someone to get married two other
brothers were trying to get sustainable
jobs that you know will last long
unless find without uh provides so my
dear brothers and sisters put your trust
in the last panel in Thailand see what
he does or you make the intention to go
for a height you all your young so that
you can enjoy and do it properly and
then see all the gifts that all aside
obviously I want to share an interesting
story with you I read an article there
was a hospice from and he wrote this
article of a man now I know that look if
someone gets sick they get cancer
whatever whatever it is I mean you go
about and you you expend your energy to
find a cure you go out there like you
know right you know in any way possible
this man did that you got him cancer I
think he had he had liver cancer and
article talks about this is the shake
that interviewed him and then he wrote
about because he was fascinated with it
so what happens is that he had exhausted
every means right and they both
basically wrote him off they told told
him that he has you know a few weeks to
live
true story and he's like what am I gonna
do now he's like I'm going to and and
they remind me because you're telling my
Hodja Nonna so he said I'm gonna go to
Omaha right and he went down there and
he met someone who told them about the
hadith where the prophet saw someone was
talking about zem zem yes so he was
talking about the zem zem and then he
ended up drinking the Zemzem water one
night he came back and he ended up the
tumor stop drawings and then it started
to reverse what do you think could you
share that had deeper thoughts until it
what are your thoughts on that was of
course you probably saw the Lavanya was
Saddam he tells us that sums them the
amount or even sums them is whatever
intention you drink it for so you heard
this amazing story that his brother
telling that he had cancer and he
started reversing I'll share my own
personal story so in 2012 before I moved
to Calgary I wanted to start off my job
on the right foot so I said you know
what let me go and perform Umrah I go on
I perform Umrah and I started realizing
that man I'm going bald my hair is
really thin expand alone I need to do
something to reverse that so halfway
between your home rock it's the Sun of
the positive seldom to go and drink some
some and he was to wipe it over his head
went over his face so at that time I
took the zum-zum I wept over mine I'm
the gala I'm too young to start going
bald and this can happen and I'll come
do a lot I mean you're not gonna see it
now with the blood spot that I had
growing like the brother was talking it
just reverse the house I have a whole
set of here now so that's just one of
the miracles of the zum-zum and
obviously there's thousands others that
you know people experience any sort of
sickness that people have people can
cure by going for hamadan and go for
hajj putting your trust in Allah
using the spiritual means a lot of the
times you get so caught up in a physical
means go to a doctor didn't cure but how
about the spiritual means Allah spinel
Tana is a chef is the one that hears and
he has given us all these tools like
Samsung and going for Hajj and Umrah and
making Doha and doing rakia and reciting
Quran and we need to take advantage of
this wall and cell phone I mean is that
amazing look you guys look at the air
it's there I mean what do you say
something really important because
obviously Islam is in something you know
that captures the hearts when people
look at the Quran right you know God
Almighty
you know caused us a lot to think to
rationale it's not like many religions
where it's just some kind of voodoo it's
something like you know pulls you and
just have faith you know
so can you can you elaborate on that you
know for some people they think oh okay
this is just like any other religion say
for they're not yet Muslims tuning in
because it's Nam is really
something that that calls you to you
know it doesn't negate science it
doesn't negate you know the rationale
the sorts the difference between the two
of course
so I often get asked how do you know
that Islam is the true religion and I
can only share from my own experience
and from what I've read so I say that in
order for the true religion to be true
it has to fulfill three things number
one it has to be logically sound that
you shouldn't be able to find loopholes
in its legislation low polls in the most
affordable preservation loophole is in
you know just the things that it's
claiming number two it has to be
spiritually enlightening meaning that it
has to make me feel as if I'm beginning
becoming a better person right and if
I'm not becoming a better person through
this religion or through this faith and
something's wrong with it because
they're supposed to be enlightenment
with faith and then number three is what
it does to an individual in terms of
connecting them to Allah Spano in sauna
like deep down inside we all know that
God exists we cover it up with sins we
covered up with other things and that's
how we learn to deny but the reality is
we know deep down the sign that he
exists so the religion that is true has
to be a direct connector to God I mean
he doesn't put up intermediaries between
you and God
it doesn't put up you know anything else
between you and what so you have a
direct relationship and that's for me is
how I feel
that Islam is the true religion because
it's mixed Ludd since logically it's
preserved to the team that you look at
the way the Quran is preserved for
centuries generation to generation
multiple people memorize the Quran
millions of people memorize the Quran
and that's how they transmit it
spiritually in light
the only religion that I know of that
five times a day takes time out of their
day to remember God and makes God the
focus and crux of their living and
everything that they do and then
connecting you directly to God which was
my third point I don't know if any other
religion it doesn't put any
intermediaries or conduits you don't
have to go to your email to seek
forgiveness you don't need to go to your
mom to get them to make du'a you can do
those things yourself so that's how I
understand Islam to be the true religion
we're going to go ahead and have some
lunch and we'll check back with you in a
few each other